nouveau numéro de reporter sur france 24
en allemagne vient de s'achever un
procès historique un ancien tortionnaire
du régime syrien a été condamné à la
prison à vie condamnation par un
tribunal pénal allemand à coblence et
non par la cour pénale internationale de
la haye car la chine et la russie qui a
des intérêts en syrie avaient mis leur
veto si un citoyen syrien a pu être
condamnée en allemagne c'est au nom d'un
principe de droit international qui
prévoit que les crimes contre l'humanité
peuvent être jugés par toute juridiction
et l'allemagne a intégré ce dispositif
dans son système judiciaire c'est ainsi
que anwar raslan officier de
renseignement syriens de haut rang a été
condamné à la prison à vie pour des
milliers de cas de torture et au moins
27 meurtres fernante 27 c'est marine
pradel ont suivi ce procès pour
l'histoire aux côtés des victimes
attention certaines images sont
difficiles
[Musique]
au confluent du rhin et de la moselle
coblence
4000 kilomètres séparent cette ville
moyenne allemande de la capitale
syrienne damas
pourtant c'est ici que se tient le tout
premier procès pour crimes contre
l'humanité contre un haut gradé syrien
ce matin le petit palais de justice de
la ville n à accueillir les victimes
familles de disparus et leurs avocats
pour le verdict près de deux ans après
l'ouverture du procès
je ne pense pas que je vais réussir à
avoir une place à l'intérieur les gens
pour la queue depuis 6 heures
tous sont venus pour entendre de la
bouche du juge allemand ces mots
coupable et crimes contre l'humanité
l'homme sur le banc c'est lui anwar
raslan chef des interrogatoires de la
branche 251 un centre de détention et de
torture des renseignements à damas
tout ce système cette organisation cette
machine qui arrêtent un torturent et
tuent les syriens c'est ça mon ennemi ce
cette structure lui il fait partie de
cette structure ce n'est pas mon ennemi
personnel
et pourtant cet avocat syrien survivants
des prisons du régime a une histoire
très personnelle avec l'accusé
anouar al bounni et kidnappé en 2006 en
pleine rue à damas par un certain anwar
raslan
dès sa sortie de prison il fuit le pays
et se réfugie à berlin en 2014 avec sa
femme et ses enfants dans ce centre pour
réfugiés
quand je suis arrivé j'habitais là dans
cet appartement au deuxième étage
trois ans après le début du soulèvement
populaire contre le régime al-assad les
syriens commencent à fuir par centaines
de milliers vers l'europe et l'allemagne
je suis passé par le sas d'entrée ici
pour sortir et c'est là que je les ai
vus pour la première fois la dans cette
petite rue devant lui son kidnappeur
anwar à cela
son regard j'ai vu tout ce qu'il m'avait
reconnu
à ce moment il ne le sait pas encore
mais d'autres défenseurs des droits de
l'homme sont déjà sur la trace de raslan
lorsqu'à noir al bounni est convoqué par
la police allemande pour faire une
déposition ils confortent les soupçons
des enquêteurs
ils m'ont appelé pour prendre mon
témoignage et m'ont demandé s'il y avait
d'autres victimes qui voulaient se
joindre à la procédure
alors bien sûr je les ai aidés parce que
la plupart des victimes et des témoins
je les connaissais déjà et je les avait
défendu à l'époque quand il avait été
arrêté et détenu au centre 251
dans son petit bureau berlinois anouar
al bounni compile les témoignages contre
raslan mais aussi contre des dizaines
d'autres criminels de guerre syriens
présents sur le sol européen
et pas un jour ne passe sans une aire
sur messenger quelqu'un à localiser un
des criminels qu'il l'a arrêté et
torturé
à l'est des manteaux jason
[Musique]
day 2 ils ont localisé
en suède ils ont reconnu son visage et
son nom et il me contacter par ce qu'ils
veulent savoir quoi faire
là maintenant vous venez de recevoir ce
message oui juste là là et ça arrive
souvent
oui tous les jours tous les jours on
reçoit des messages comme ça
de partout en europe oui partout
[Musique]
en 2019 anwar à cela elle est arrêtée
ainsi qu'un de ses subordonnés au sein
de la branche 251
il faut préparer le futur procès un
procès non pas à la cour pénale
internationale à cause des veto russe et
chinois mais un procès de droit allemand
avec des avocats allemands
comme patrick crocker
il représente 9 des 24 survivants qui
composent les parties civiles
en droit pénal international il y à
cette idée que si les crimes sont si
graves qu'ils deviennent des crimes
internationaux comme les crimes contre
l'humanité les crimes de guerre où les
crimes de génocide il ya un principe
appelé la compétence universelle qui
fait que ces crimes peuvent être
poursuivis n'importe où dans le monde
bien sûr cela dépend de l'état de
comment chaque pays incorpore ce
principe de compétence universelle dans
son propre droit
et l'allemagne en l'occurrence l'a fait
de façon très large
c'est pour cette raison que le procureur
fédéral allemand a pu commencer à
enquêter sur les dossiers syrien dès
cela fait quatre ans que patrick rockeur
travaille sur ce dossier
convaincre ses clients d'aller témoigner
devant le tribunal n'a pas été facile
car même réfugiés sur le sol européen la
peur est toujours là
les services secrets syriens les
mukhabarat ils viennent taper à votre
porte je veux dire chez votre père votre
neveu votre frère votre mère ils disent
écoutez on a appris que votre fils ou
votre nièce veut témoigner au tribunal
de coblence on n'est pas très contents
vous devriez vraiment lui parler
le message est très clair pour tout le
monde la prochaine étape c'est que cette
personne va se retrouver en prison et
sera torturé
parmi ces survivants
rawhide à cannes
aujourd'hui elle est réfugié politique
en france est étudiante à l'université
mais au début de la révolution en syrie
la jeune journaliste de radio rêves de
démocratie et de liberté
en 2012 elle est arrêtée à damas et
conduite au centre 251 fin
quand je suis arrivé à la branche 251 la
torture a commencé ibadan
il traiter les détenus comme des choses
pas comme des personnes
pour eux il n'y a aucune limite à la
douleur rires boeuf vous faire endurer
lorsqu'ils m'ont emmené à
l'interrogatoire ils m'ont battue et
j'ai vu des jeunes hommes pendus au
plafond par les poignets les uns à côté
des autres minutes en train d'être
battus
tous les jours il y en avait des
nouveaux après l'arrestation de race
lanouaille da seront à berlin pour être
interrogé par la police
10h02 questions intimes est difficile
c'était fatigant sur le plan
psychologique et physique et cela m'a
rappelé un souvenir que j'essaie
d'oublier
puis en novembre 2020 elle vient
témoigner devant la cour à coblence face
à elle sur le banc des accusés anwar
raslan
élèves loi je le regardais tout le temps
je voulais qu'il me regarde je voulais
lui dire voilà maintenant toi et moi on
est tous les deux devant un tribunal en
quatre heures d'audience il ne m'a
jamais regardé jamais la faim et non
le principal défi du procès c'est de
prouver le caractère systématique et
institutionnalisé des tortures
ce qui va faire de ces crimes des crimes
contre l'humanité
dans ce sous sol d'une grande ville
d'europe de l'ouest
900 kg de papier 1 million de documents
les actes administratifs de la machine
de mort syrienne
signé des mains de boer aux bureaucrates
dont bachar al assad en personne
merma jelasic codirige la cidj à la
commission pour la justice
internationale et la responsabilité des
crimes elle est un des trois visages
connus de l'organisation sur une
centaine de membres tous anonymes
nos équipes ont été ciblés aussi bien en
syrie qu'à l'étranger
alors nous avons dû mettre en place des
règles de sécurité très strictes aux us
et les fois où on a eu des brèches dans
le protocole de sécurité on a dû tout
modifié on a été contraint de déménager
de changer de pays plusieurs fois déjà
et steve lacy déjà à exfiltrer la
plupart de ces documents des bâtiments
officiels syriens quand une grande
partie du territoire étaient aux mains
de l'opposition jusqu'en 2016
et dans la masse ils ont retrouvé des
comptes rendus d'interrogatoires
signé de la main d'un noir à cela
les documents de la cia sont très
importants
parce qu'il montre l'implication directe
et de l'accusé
mais aussi parce qu'il montre son rôle
et celui de ses équipes dans ce
tentaculaire archipel de violence et de
torture qui étaient déployés par le
régime
un autre élément clé du procès les
photos du dossier césar du nom d'un
officier des renseignements militaires
qui a exfiltré de syrie les photos des
corps de plus de 6000 syrien morts de
faim et de tortures dans les centres de
détention du régime
saleh une privation de nourriture
là c'est une mort due à un choc brutal
sur la nuque
c'est la compression des tissus du coup
cet expert légiste a passé trois ans à
analyser 27 mille clichés du dossier
devant la cour il les a détaillées
cliniquement se foutent rien à la fin et
parce qu'on l'a étudié ces photos sur
longue période on est arrivé au point où
on pensait avoir déjà travaillé sur une
photo je me disais je me suis trompé
j'ai repris un dossier déjà étudié et je
me retrouve à analyser une photo sur
laquelle j'ai déjà travaillé
jusqu'à ce que ça devienne clair à un
moment donné oui les cas sont en fait
très similaire au sein d'une prison mais
aussi entre les différents centres de
détention
et c'est comme ça que nous avons apporté
les preuves de l'existence d'une forme
de système qui régit la façon dont les
gens sont traités et sont blessés dans
ces prisons
anwar haslam admet que la torture était
systématique mais nie toute implication
personnelle
à paris roanne à cannes et c'est
d'oublier
[Musique]
mais une dernière fois elle a choisi
d'aller s'asseoir face à son bourreau
[Musique]
side j'ai du mal à me réjouir parce que
je pense à mes amis qui sont encore en
détention at il un masque il serait
content de ce qu'on fait ici
je ne sais pas
[Musique]
jeudi 13 janvier après 100 jours
d'audience le procès arrive à son terme
j'ai essayé de dormir mais je n'y
arrivais pas je pensais tout le temps à
ce qui allait se passer aujourd'hui
deux heures plus tard le verdict est
annoncée la prison à vie pour un noir à
cela
s'est il
contenté tic la cour dénonce cet état
sécuritaire qui commet des crimes c'est
un grand jour pour la série
après ça je ne vois pas comment un pays
qui respecte les droits de l'homme
pourrait encore parler avec le régime
d'assad
dix-sept ans après avoir croisé son
bourreau dans la rue anouar al bounni
peut tourner cette page 6 et se
concentrer sur les autres
de nombreux procès vont s'ouvrir en
autriche en allemagne en suède aux pays
bas en belgique en suisse
nous continuons notre mission ce n'est
pas un boulot pour moi c'est ma mission
c'est ma vie alors tant que je vis ce
combat continue
vous pensez qu'un jour bachar al assad
sera jugé
j'en suis sûr ce n'est pas un espoir
pour moi c'est mon objectif au goal
une semaine plus tard à francfort
s'ouvre le procès d'un médecin syriens
accusé d'avoir achevé des manifestants
dans les hôpitaux pour le compte du
régime
lui aussi pensait s'être retrouvé une
nouvelle vie en europe
m et
voilà pour ce reportage de fernande
vantage et marine pradel sur ce procès
en allemagne qui sera suivie
prochainement par d'autres c'est la fin
de ce magazine merci de l'avoir suivi on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de reporter sur france
venu
[Musique]